as we get ready to go into the Cabinet
Room where the president is meeting with
his national I just heard that they
broke into the office of one of my
personal attorneys good man and it's a
disgraceful situation it's a total witch
hunt I've been saying it for a long time
I've wanted to keep it down we've given
I believe over a million pages worth of
documents to the special counsel they
continue to just go forward and here we
are talking about Syria we're talking
about a lot of serious things with the
greatest fighting force ever and I have
this witch hunt
constantly going on for over 12 months
now and actually much more than that you
could say it was right after I won the
nomination it started and it's a
disgrace it's frankly a real disgrace
it's a an attack on our country in a
true sense it's an attack on what we all
stand for so when I saw this and what I
heard it I heard it like you did I said
that is really now at a whole new level
of unfairness so this has been going on
I saw one of the reporters who is not
necessarily a fan of mine not
necessarily very good to me he said in
effect that this is ridiculous this is
now getting ridiculous they found no
collusion whatsoever with Russia the
reason they found it is there was no
collusion at all no collusion this is
the most biased group of people these
people have the biggest conflicts of
interest I've ever seen
Democrats all just about all either
Democrats or a couple of Republicans
that work for President Obama they're
not looking at the other side they're
not looking at the Hillary Clinton
horrible things that she did and all of
the crimes that were committed they're
not looking at all of the things that
happened
everybody is very angry about I can tell
you from the Republican side and I think
even the independent side they only keep
looking at us so they find no collusion
and then they go from there and they say
well let's keep going and they raid an
office of a personal attorney early in
the morning and I think it's a disgrace
so we'll be talking about it more but
this is the most conflicted group of
people I've ever seen the Attorney
General made a terrible mistake when he
did this and when he recused himself or
he should have certainly let us know if
he was going to recuse himself and we
would have fused they put a different
Attorney General in so he made what I
consider to be a very terrible mistake
for the country but you'll figure that
out all I can say is after looking for a
long period of time not even before the
special counsel because it really
started just about from the time I won
the nomination and you look at what took
place and what happened and it's a
disgrace it's a disgrace I've been
president now for what seems like a
lengthy period of time we've done a
fantastic job we've beaten Isis we have
just about a hundred percent of the
Caliphate or the land our economy is
incredible the stock market dropped a
lot today as soon as they heard the
noise of you know this nonsense that's
going on it dropped a lot it was up way
up and then it dropped quite a bit at
the end a lot but that we have to go
through that we've had that hanging over
us now from the very very beginning and
yet the other side they don't even
bother looking and the other side is
where there are crimes and those crimes
are obvious lies under oath all over the
place emails that are knocked out that
are acid-washed and deleted nobody's
ever seen 33,000 emails have deleted
after getting a subpoena for Congress
and nobody bothers looking at that and
many many other things so I just think
it's a disgrace that a thing like this
can happen